[موسيقى]
ان الوضع هذا عند اثار على دوار وعلى
المحيط الاقليمي والدولي على سبيل المثال
الان قضيه السلاح والتجاره في السلاح
والهجره غير شرعيه وتجاره المخدرات وتجاره
الترامادول وكل انواع
الهجره الى اوروبا
حتى التنظيمات اللي موجوده جنوب الصحراء
هي معروفه حضرتك تعرفيها تنظيمات القاعده
والتنظيمات الاسلاميه اداء البطاقه كلها
الان موجوده في منطقه الجنوب فنحن امام
مواقع سيء للنجيب يا مش دوله يعني موقعها
ليبيا تقع على جنوب الابيض البحر الابيض
المتوسط في 2000 كيلو متر في مواجهه
مباشره مع اليونان مع ايطاليا مع فرنسا
همم اقصد يعني من حيث الموقع اللي همم
الجغرافي
لان هذه الدول
ومن خلف دول كثيره يعني خاصه المجموعات
الارهابيه سيكون لها اثر سيئه جدا على
المحيط هو كان على مصر على تونس على حتى
الخليج العربي على المغرب العربي
[موسيقى]
ممكن ترد يعني
السياسيون اذا كان ارادوا انهم ينتخبوا
حكومه جديده من خلال مجلس النواب
وبالتوفيق حتى مع مجلس الدوله ولا اي جسم
كان لن يحترف بها دوليا اذن العامل الدولي
هو اساس الموضوع الليبي نتيجه
وضعت تحت الفصل السابع في عام 2011
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]